more than a decade before universal's
attempted dark universe and its tom
cruise led mummy reboot their original
efforts at bringing the classic monster
back to the big screen were certified
hits the mummy trilogy which kicked off
in 1999 and concluded with 2008's
critically panned the mummy tomb of the
dragon emperor killed it at the box
office raking in a collective 1.25
billion dollars worldwide a major reason
for the success of the first two mummy
films was the solid cast which helped
revitalize the action-adventure genre by
infusing it with both horror and comedy
they took what could have been a set of
campy period films and made them appeal
to a younger audience through witty
dialogue and thrilling action most
generally tout brendan fraser as rick
o'connell as the centerpiece of the
mummy universe
but rising star rachel vice's work as
evelyn evie o'connell proved just as
integral
vice's performance in the mummy turned
out to be her big break she signed on to
do the mummy returns without question
but she's mysteriously absent from tomb
of the dragon emperor in which maria
bello played evie instead
the reason for vice's departure from the
project was actually laid to rest nearly
12 years ago but hasn't necessarily
become common knowledge
when talks of a third film and the mummy
continuity began to pick up steam back
in 2007 so did discussions about why
rachel vice wasn't attached to the
project one common rumor ran rampant
about her distaste for the script which
she reportedly felt went against evie's
character
another was started by director rob
cohen who believed it had something to
do with rick and evie's 27 year old son
alex whose inclusion would require vice
to be aged up for the third movie
vice put the whole debacle to bed during
an interview back in 2008 when she
explained that she never got the chance
to even look at the script she'd also
just finished on ryan johnson's the
brothers bloom and was about to begin
work on another film immediately so she
wouldn't have a moment to spare couple
that with her and darren aronofsky's
newborn son waiting for her at home
there was no time for a trip to china
for five months
tomb of the dragon emperor was a
critical flop and prompted universal to
rethink their plans for a follow-up
based around the aztecs little did vice
know back then that she couldn't have
pulled out of the series at a better
time
hey
um
sorry i blamed you guys for raising the
emperor
to say the mummy tomb of the dragon
emperor suffered without vice would be
an understatement
the film is the lowest rated of the
trilogy with an abysmal 12 percent
critic score on rotten tomatoes
moviegoers didn't find it charming
either as its audience score was only
slightly better at 30 percent in the
audience comments on the aggregator site
many franchise fans noted that the film
took a hit with vice's absence one
viewer wrote
ultimately the absence of rachel vice
and the change in location and mythology
are the biggest flaws in this film
vice was a major part of the first two
films and by having her replaced by
maria bello the original character is
lost and replaced with one that doesn't
meet vice's performance
swapping out actors at the end of a
trilogy is a huge risk we wonder if it
might have been better to leave out evie
entirely to not frustrate and confuse
the franchise's fans
while vice wasn't in the film there was
a nice homage to her
is the scarlett o'keefe character really
based on you
honestly i can say she's a completely
different person
bellow praised the moment in an
interview with collider saying
it was a great comment on it i liked the
idea that i wrote novels and the woman i
wrote was this amazing beautiful rachel
vice ingenue and she was the character
because she's so perfect
and then there's me in my mansion bored
to death
following the release of tomb of the
dragon emperor bella was on board for
another mummy film but universal
cancelled project in 2012 the tom cruise
mummy reboot in 2017 flopped hard
killing the planned dark universe
so who knows what's in store for the
franchise it just might come back to
life
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]